number one major lead Whiffle draft pick  and die hard Yankees fan takes on  Houston right outside Minute Maid  Stadium but there's no chirping going on  with the ball pool planet  [Music]  one and two he's getting the heater see  what he does with it  I don't like Houston  I don't think a buzzer or a trash can is  gonna help this guy  another one steps in  and it's about to step out he's from New  York he's a Yankees fan  he's touching like 90 right oh he's  showing Buzz he's gonna do that to him  you're the first you're the first person  today  who do you think will be the MVP of the  ALDS not anybody from the astross  let's go Seattle let's go Seattle baby  you're not better dragging out Astros  game for a day